throughout the conflict in Ukraine
significant territorial shifts have
occurred Russia at one point Advanced
close to Major Urban centers occupying
farmlands and strategic rural areas
while their military presence has since
diminished they've left a lasting and
destructive Legacy on Ukrainian soil
landmines a cruel and long- Lasting
weapon designed to act as a deterrent
for military personnel moving in to
recapture land taken from them however
once the positions are abandoned the
stay concealed underground they continue
to pose significant threats for years or
decades after the conflict's conclusion
hindering agricultural activities
restricting civilian mobility and
causing lasting trauma starting in 2014
with the Russian occupation of Crimea
the south of Ukraine became contaminated
with minefields 7 years of tedious work
went into de mining an area of 23,000
Square km in 18 months all that work
went to waste as this area plus another
150,000 km is now contaminated with
mines once again this accounts for 30%
of Ukraine's total land area roughly the
size of Florida making Ukraine the
country with the largest area
contaminated by mines the regions
affected are concentrated in the East
where most of the conflict is happening
but also include areas near the
country's capital where the Russian army
got worryingly close in 2022 these mines
are already starting to take a toll on
the Ukrainian people as 298 civilians
have been killed 22 of them being
children with over 600 injured
unfortunately these numbers are only
going to grow it is estimated that it
will take Ukraine 750 years to clear its
land using current Dem Mining and
detection techniques so what exactly are
landmines and what tools do we have to
detect and Destroy them let's delve
deeper into the pain painful task facing
Ukraine there are two types of landmines
larger ones that are designed to disable
or destroy large Vehicles like tanks and
smaller ones designed to MIM individuals
and Ukraine is unfortunately littered
with both the Russian pfm 1 is a small
plastic case mine filled with 37 G of
liquid explosives nicknamed The
Butterfly mine their small wings allow
them to be dropped from the air whether
by mortar helicopter or Airplane the
unsymmetrical wings allow them to Glide
and spin to the ground like a helicopter
seed Landing Softly on the ground
waiting for an unsuspecting victim when
stood on the thin plastic deforms which
increases the pressure on the liquid
inside the casing causing it to explode
because they are camouflaged and contain
little metal detection of these Sinister
weapons is extremely challenging their
lightweight nature allows them to be
carried by water potentially reaching
civilian areas where children can
mistake them for toys making them
particularly inhuman the Russian pmn2
land mine is a general purpose mine that
also uses a plastic casing to minimize
metal components it is buried between 5
to 10 cm below the surface and contains
around 100 G of TNT it detonates with a
weight of only 15 kg low enough to be
triggered by stepping on it but mines
aren't only activated by pressure
pressure to create imped Ms along roads
or entrances to buildings the O M72
landmine uses a trip wire as a trigger
to explode 660 G of TNT anti-tank mines
unlike those targeting individuals
require more TNT to penetrate heavily
armored tanks and are designed to
detonate under larger pressures the M1
Abrams Tanks recently sent to Ukraine
will face the tm62 land mine which
detonate only when objects wne over 50
kg pass over them delivering a powerful
7.5 kg TNT explosion since 2021 the
Russian army has employed the PT km 1R a
novel mine designed to Target the upper
and less armored sections of the tank
the mine is not triggered by passing
over it instead it is equipped with two
seismic sensors for the detection of
tank movement and four microphones to
capture loud sounds once a tank is
detected it tilts 60° towards the Target
and launches ammunition 30 m above the
tank in a parabolic trajectory infrared
and radar sensors activate the second
explosive phase deploying a shaped
charge to penetrate the tank from above
tools to help detect and Destroy these
mines have come mostly from the US
anti-mine equipment is listed as part of
the latest $600 million package to
Ukraine in September
20123 so what do these tools look like
the tools chosen to demine an area
depend on the current phase of the
conflict and the land's intended use
after the mine has been removed military
demining intended to establish secure
Pathways for highly trained soldiers and
heavily reinforced equipment is carried
out very differently from Dem mining
efforts in civilian areas used for
farming or where children will play
freely so how does the military deal
with these mines with Brute Force mind
clearance line charges can create a
secure path in minutes these are lines
containing C4 explosive pellets attached
to a central nylon rope along with
detonation wires the line is attached to
a solid propellant rocket placed on an
angled guide when fired it pulls the 100
m line taut along the desired path then
the line is detonated the explosion
creates enough pressure to detonate any
mines below the surface and 4 M to each
side of the line if a longer path is
needed the machine Will Roll Along the
recently created path and repeat the
process
this method prioritizes speed for when
enemies are nearby or troops need to
move quickly to the front lines but this
method comes at a high cost each line
cost
$83,000 but water of speed is not as
important like when the enemy has
retreated and you need to secure key
positions in some cases Fields have been
set on fire in Ukraine to clear them of
the small plastic pfm 1 mine armored
tanks resistant to smaller mine
explosions outfitted with two tools to
either detonate or push aide mines can
also be used one method uses chain link
flails as the vehicle moves forward
these flails strike and detonate the
mines this often breaks the flail
causing chain links to fly off into the
distance but additional links can easily
be attached to repair them detonation
may not always be necessary to clear a
path a plow attachment on the M1 Abram's
tank can dig into the soil beneath the
mines and push them aside out of the way
without triggering them from above in
recent years smaller remote controlled
flailed vehicles have started to operate
too Ukrainian Farmers desperate to start
cultivating again have even retrofitted
some of their farming equipment to be
remote controlled and have started to
unofficially demine their lands using
armored vehicles like these for mine
clearing does have some limitations they
are unsuitable for rough terrain and
dense vegetation where maneuverability
is compromised in open areas such as
those in Ukraine they can also become a
conspicuous Target that the enemy can
anticipate Ukrainian soldiers have
reported that the leopard tank is
particularly vulnerable when engaged in
Minefield clearance it is frequently
targeted by the Russian army since
disabling the tank will significantly
impede the Ukrainian Force's progress
these methods can remove 80 to 90% of
mines mines that do not detonate either
become further buried or remain
alongside the cleared path within
military standards this level of
effective is considered acceptable as
soldiers are trained to spot mines on
the ground and can more easily navigate
and avoid them the last 10 to 20% of
Mines are the ones that stay in the
ground or if a military operation does
not pass through a contaminated area the
mines stay there until a civilian gets
injured removing these mines is known as
humanitarian Dem mining Ukraine is not
the first country to be scattered with
mines in civilian areas Cambodia was
infested with landmines during the ch
regime three decades later only half of
the land has been cleared and they have
already claimed the lives of 64,000
people even highly trafficked tourist
regions like CM reap have ominous mind
warning signs a constant reminder not to
venture off the beaten paths surrounding
cambodia's ancient temples and the
devastation these Minds have had on the
civilian population is a confronting
reminder to tourists of the very recent
genocide the country ured in Afghanistan
landmines were indiscriminate
permanently laid during the Soviet
occupation Between 1979 and 1992 and
continue to be laid by the Taliban today
this has injured or killed almost 57,000
people in the country in 2021 79% of the
casualties were children a small town in
mosm Beek was evacuated due to rumors of
mines in the surrounding area 3 months
later only four were found the power of
landmines not only come from their
instant destructive capabilities but
also their ability to scare people away
these are inhumane weapons that
disproportionately kill and MIM innocent
civilians long after the conflict is
resolved in early 2022 a dam near kir in
Ukraine was destroyed the estimated 500
mines in the area that were not properly
removed or destroyed by the military
have now potentially been dispersed by
the floods they may be buried deeper
under debris or end up in entirely new
locations on uncleared mines are a major
humanitarian challenge especially as the
UN standard requires 100% clearance rate
within designated zones of course to
prevent harm from these mines the first
step is to cease their use entirely the
Ottawa treaty also known as the mine Ban
Treaty prohibits the use production
stockpiling and transfer of smaller
anti-personnel mines excluding those
targeting tanks the Ottawa treaty has
been widely embraced by the
international Community with over 160
signatory countries unsurprisingly it
excludes Russia the US China India and
Pakistan the world's largest military
forces the US reserved the right to use
so-called non-persistent landmines which
self-destruct or self deactivate after
30 days to reduce the risk to civilians
the rationale behind this policy was to
support the defense of South Korea where
landmines play a significant role as a
deterrent against potential aggression
from North Korea Russia told the UN in
2020 that it supports the world without
mines but they still see them as an
essential tool to ensure border security
when not on the front line the method
for locating these mines primarily
involves the use of metal detectors
metal detectors are a simple tool any
metal in the soil interacts with this
detector and causes an audible beep for
the user the user's sole source of
information is the strength of this beep
which communicates the size and
proximity of the object consequently
operators must undergo rigorous training
to interpret the auditory cues upon
hearing a beep D Miner is moved to
investigate the alarm the most common
way to do this is using a small stick at
an angle to avoid the top of the mine
they poke the area in search of
something solid the probe can be
anything from a screwdriver to more
sensitive Force measuring probing sticks
that help assess the hardness of buried
metal allowing for the differentiation
of trapnel from potential landmines this
is a slow and tedious process that just
adds stress to the already pressured de
miners here lies the problem with using
these simple tools they detect any sort
of metal in the ground it can be either
a mine or some shrapnel in war torn
areas where shrapnel is common soldiers
looking for mines get false alarms
between 100 to 1,000 times for every
mine they discover to develop more
advanced de mining systems the US Army
initiated a sub substantial investment
in 1992 allocating a total of $73
million over a 15-year period the
objective was to establish the gold
standard in Dem mining Technologies
resulting in the handheld standoff mine
detection system in 2006 the system uses
two sensors combining a metal detector
with a ground penetrating radar the
radar gives the operator a better idea
of the size geometry and depth of the
detected object allowing them to filter
out false positives that metal detectors
frequently provide since its
introduction it's been used in Cambodia
Thailand Afghanistan and Croatia to find
56,000 mines and reject 33 million false
signals alternatively we can detect
mines through their smell dogs have been
successfully trained to identify mines
including the famous Jack Russell
Terrier of the Ukraine war who has
helped detect hundreds of explosives
small dogs are ideal for the job as they
are too light to trigger mins rats are
useful for the same reason off the-shelf
drones can also detect signs of Mines
that have been buried and in situations
where landmines are placed directly on
the ground or dispersed from the air
like the pfm 1 drones can simply go up
and spot them from above however efforts
are being made to develop Machine Vision
algorithms with both visible and
infrared spectrums to detect these
landmines automatically and they could
potentially be fitted with projectiles
to Target the mine from the air
landmines will continue to plague
Ukraine for the coming decades even if
the war ends now hopefully these new
techniques and Technologies can
accelerate the clearance of this new
colossal Minefield but Ukraine also
needs additional resources to clear the
way for their advancing soldiers so to
play our part we'll be donating $2,000
to the Halo trust an NGO dedicated to
clearing minefields around the world
including Ukraine while campaigning for
the Banning of Mines altogether that
money will be coming directly out of our
spot sponsor fee for nebula and for
every one of you that signs up to nebula
with the link in the description we will
donate another dollar to the cause it
costs just 250 to sign up to nebula for
a month so that's 40% of your monthly
fee going directly to charity and you
will get access to all the amazing
content on nebula 2 including the next
episode of real engineering which won't
be on YouTube for another 2 weeks it
details the incredible engineering of
the F-16 diving into energy
maneuverability diagrams and what makes
the F-16 a formidable tool for the
Ukrainian Air Force four decades after
its first flight with an interview from
an experienced test pilot and former
F-16 pilot David Kar you can get access
to that right now with the huge
discounted price of just 250 a month
using the link in the description but
early access to our videos is just one
benefit you will also get access to our
original World War II series the
logistics of D-Day and the Battle of
Britain as well as real life lore's
modern conflict series that deep dives
into conflicts like the war in Ukraine
along with originals from some of your
favorite creators like mustard practical
engineering Neo and went over
Productions nebula is simply the best
place to watch our videos no ads Early
Access to our videos and exclusive High
budget Originals all for the price of
250 a
month